this video is sponsored by brilliant org
the Star Wars saga currently consists of
eight films the original trilogy the
ones the memes come from lame is in
space and a new hope to electric
boogaloo within these films were
introduced to 28 planets and moons
ranging from the plains of Naboo to the
deserts of Tatooine to the larva of
Mustafar to the whatever this is of
Felucia a lot of these planets are
clearly inspired by biomes on earth such
as the grasslands of Europe the Sahara
Desert and the lava of Hawaii but
scaling up one part of the earth to a
whole planet doesn't always work within
the laws of physics and one of the
planets that we see in star wars could
exist in the real universe though and we
actually have observations of similar
planets around other stars a little
closer to home but yes some of them are
definitely in the realm of science
fiction that's the voice of dr. Hannah
waetford an exoplanet researcher at the
Space Telescope Science Institute with
her knowledge of planetary science my
knowledge about spirit physics and the
star wars Wikipedia which is called
Wikipedia because of course it is we can
work out which planets in the star wars
universe could really exist
to begin with several planets almost
identical to the earth having lots of
different biomes polar caps and a
planetary radius of about 6400
kilometers so Nabu takodana Alderaan
Cato Neimoidia and Rabbani can
definitely exist two more planets which
are very similar to the earth are gavin
for the location of the rebel base in a
new hope and Kashyyyk the homeworld of
the Wookiees but could they exist yemen
4 is a large moon not much smaller than
the earth orbiting the humongous gas
giant yabin yeah been so big that it's
even really low density which would have
to be caused by some strong internal
heating or it's on the very edge of what
we would even call a planet we know that
brown dwarfs which are massive objects
that are bigger than planets but not
quite massive enough to turn into stars
can all the other stars and we also know
that brown dwarfs can host planets so
the existence of the moon in itself
isn't impossible the issue here is that
orbiting so closely Abin would cause
humongous amounts of tidal heating this
is the effect of the near Side of the
Moon filling the greater gravitational
pull to the planet than the far side in
addition to this Gavin has several other
moons which are similar in size to Yavin
4 which would pull on the moon outwards
when thereby the combination of these
two factors would cause major frictional
heating of the moon's interior which
would cause the moon to be extremely
geologically active this is exactly what
we see on Io the fifth known moon of
Jupiter
it has over 400 active volcanoes and is
the most geologically active place in
the entire solar system
Gavin 4 isn't shown to have any volcanic
activity and though its wiki page
suggests that it experienced some in the
past this should continue as the effects
of tidal heating will not diminish over
time so yeah man 4 as it is shown in the
movies could not exist so close to such
a large planet Kashyyyk yes thank you is
described as having a perfectly circular
orbit meaning it stays the same constant
distance from its star and also has no
axial tilt the angle between the planets
rotation and its orbit around the star
these two combined result in the planet
having
one continuous season as all parts of
the planet received constant solar
heating year-round there are two planets
in the solar system which actually
exhibit these two characteristics
mercury has almost no axial tilt and
Venus hasn't almost perfectly circular
orbit so while it's possible that these
two characteristics could coincide and
they would indeed produce a lack of
seasons this would be very unlikely so
because she gets a maybe several other
Star Wars planets are also similar to
what we see in the solar system
Tatooine for example is a combination of
Mars's dry climate with Earth's thicker
atmosphere jakku Jeddah and Geonosis are
also very similar particularly jakku as
it once had water which has since frozen
or been lost which is exactly what we
currently think happened on Mars the
interesting thing about Tatooine is that
it's in a binary star system a planet
orbiting two stars which orbit each
other this gives it its famous twin
sunsets binary stars are in fact the
most numerous certainly in our galaxy
and binary stars have been observed to
have planets around them the first
discovered was called Kepler 16b which
much like Tatooine orbiting two stars
one yellow and one red but you can have
many types of binary systems Tatooine is
likely in what is called a p-type binary
orbit where it goes around both of the
stars but you can also get S type
binaries where the planet orbits one of
the stars but not the other but you
would still often see two suns in the
sky in both of these configurations this
also applies to another planet with two
suns Endor the home of the Ewoks
so Tatooine jakku jeddah Geonosis and
Endor can all exist but there's one more
planet which is very similar to a planet
in our solar system first but it's
pretty far what I think we make it
morning Tony best bin is a gas giant
about the size of Saturn where a cloud
city floats in a breathable layer of the
atmosphere from the gas giants in our
solar system it's very clear that it's
not plausible for a breathable
stratified layer to exist in the planets
upper atmosphere where cloud city is if
we move the gas giant close enough to
star we might be able to get some upper
parts of the atmosphere hot enough that
everything would not freeze but that's
just the first challenge saying we have
the right temperature at the right
pressure in the atmosphere where human
lungs could survive next we have to have
the material to form breathable air and
we have to keep it there the air we
breathe is mostly molecular nitrogen and
oxygen if we combine this in the 8020
ratio of the Earth's atmosphere this
would have a mass around 12 times that
of hydrogen and helium which would be
making up the majority of the gas in a
gas giant planet if the atmosphere is
then stratified into layers this layer
would be much much deeper in the
atmosphere it's much heavier where the
pressures would be far too high for
humans to survive and temperatures would
be much hotter too so sadly bespin
doesn't make the cut this still leaves
us with plenty of planets though some of
which have parallels in the Earth's past
or Pinhas future the frozen planet of
Hoth for example is what the earth is
hypothesized to have looked like several
times in its past during periods known
as snowball earth during the last of
these hypothesized episodes about 650
million years ago atmospheric oxygen
would have been at a level which was
breathable so Hoth as it's shown in the
films has historical precedent Mustafar
by contrast is an extremely volcanically
active moon which is covered in lava
flows and active volcanoes this
resembles another period in the Earth's
history the Hadean the Hadean was an
epoch about 4 billion years ago when
conditions on the earth were literally
hellish extremely hot with molten rocks
covering the surface and the planet
being hit by a huge number of meteorites
the difference between the Hadean earth
and mooster fire however is that while
Anakin and obi-wan are able to breathe
perfectly normally on most afar the
atmosphere of Earth during the Hadean
was
very dense an almost entirely carbon
dioxide which isn't exactly breathable
even to a Jedi
so mr. fire as shown in the movies just
doesn't really make any sense
I mean of all the people of Darth I
thought you'd be happy about that
Felucia is a planet that briefly
features an episode free but is
completely distinct from all of the
others being a multicolored jungle of
huge plants the planet itself is a bit
smaller than the earth and so has a
surface gravity about 75% of the earth
this would help the plants to grow to
greatest sizes and apart from the colors
this is pretty similar to earth during
the Cambrian about 500 million years ago
so assuming the atmosphere of Felucia
can mix nutrients and water around the
planet with strong circulation it could
exist two planets which resemble what
the earth might look like in the future
our chorus ant and hosnian prime both
being densely populated planets about
the same size as Earth chorus ants
actually listed on Wikipedia as having a
population of 1 trillion beings and
judging by the cities shown in the film
this also seems about right for hos nyan
prime this you here is the earth with a
population of just seven billion people
is becoming hotter and hotter due to the
buildup of gases like carbon dioxide and
methane in its atmosphere the effect of
one trillion people on a similarly sized
planet doing similar industries would be
absolutely devastating so either
Khorasan Sandoz nyan prime are doing
some serious geoengineering not
impossible given the technology and star
wars or they should be substantially
hotter than they are shown to be so they
get a maybe later when he does that a
planet with a similar issue is II do
which is shown to be covered in dense
clouds and storms water vapor is
actually a tremendously powerful
greenhouse gas strongly absorbing
thermal wavelengths of radiation so
assuming the e DS orbiting a star
similar to our own at a similar distance
it should actually be boiling hot but it
of course could be orbiting a weaker
star or further away so it could still
exist two planets from the newer films
which is very similar are Dakar and lamu
relatively small terrestrial planets
which have rings similar to Saturn we
think of rings as being around gas
giants like so
in Uranus but it's always been
theoretically possible for small
terrestrial planets like Earth to
maintain a ring system and recently in
October 2017 it was discovered that
there's a ring system around the dwarf
planet how Mayo which orbits in our
solar system just outside of Neptune so
it's been shown to be possible for small
terrestrial planets even weird tiny
elongated ones like our mayor to have
rings there are differences between the
rings though Dakar has rings which are
composed of loose rocks consistent with
a disintegrated moon or two that could
definitely exist lamu on the other hand
looks to have rings like Saturn made of
tiny ice and dust grains the eye
suggests that the planet form much
further out in the star system than the
habitable zone the range of orbits where
liquid water can exist on the surface of
a planet this is kind of possible if the
habitable zone of the star moved over
time to allow that planet to then become
habitable or possibly there's a very
strong greenhouse effect on the moon
this still would probably impact the
composition of the Rings that we see so
it's a tentative maybe for the moon this
leaves seven planets which don't have
direct analogs either in our solar
system or in the Earth's past and if an
item does not appear in our records it
does not exist sheesh
however for the past 30 years or so
we've observed planets around other
stars or exoplanets some of which are
similar to planets in our solar system
but many more are truly weird there are
a number of techniques we use to observe
exoplanets the first was called radial
velocity this simply measures the pool
the planet has on the star light over
time causing a Doppler shift in the
light as it moved towards us and away
from us due to the pull of its planet
but the most prolific method being used
is the transit method this measures the
change in the amount of light seen of a
star as the planet passes in front of it
and blocks out some of that light from
observations of thousands of exoplanets
in our region of the galaxy alone we
know that the most common type of
planets are ones we don't actually see
in our own solar system once in between
the size of our rocky earth and the icy
Giants Uranus and Neptune one class of
planets and star wars are the water
world's Kamino at toe and
scare off' these are planets which are
almost completely covered in ocean with
only small islands jutting above the
water we know that several bodies in the
solar system contain water including the
moons Europa Enceladus and Ganymede but
only earth has liquid water on the
surface and while we can't directly
observe liquid surface water on
exoplanets we can use other measurements
as proxies like the amount of water
vapour in the atmosphere of an exoplanet
using these proxies we've discovered
several objects which could potentially
be ocean planets such as the mini
Neptune GJ 1214b observations of GJ
1214b so far suggest that it's a world
shrouded in optically thick clouds which
would block out most of the star's light
making the surface if there is one very
eerie and dark so while we don't have
direct observations of ocean planets
there's nothing in planetary science
that says they couldn't exist and we
have pretty good evidence that they
should so Kamino backto and scare off'
are quite possible another planet which
is almost a water world is Dagobah where
Master Yoda makes his home the whole
planet is one massive swamp teeming with
life which implies that the planet is
almost completely flat and waterlogged
in fact the Wikipedia page for Dagobah
says that the planet is volcanic Li dead
with only small remnants of any tectonic
activity remaining such as the smooth
down remains of Mount Yoda really we
think of planets as being geologically
active because that's what the earth is
like constantly shifting and changing
thanks to continental drift and new land
being formed by volcanic action but that
tectonic activity can just stop similar
to jakku this is what we think happened
on Mars there are plenty of features
such as the huge Valles Marineris and
Olympus Mons which indicate that there
was tectonic activity in the past but as
the planet cooled the molten rock
between the tectonic plates solidified
and the planet became volcanic Li dead
it seems like the same thing happened on
Dagobah so it could exist this leaves us
with three final planets which are truly
weird due to power my Guiteau and the
invitingly named star killer base
T'Pau is a really old one it's very
similar to Earth in terms of the
composition and size but all the oceans
have drained through holes which used to
be magma chambers leaving the planet
barren and covered in sinkholes with
subsurface oceans there are a few
problems with this I actually got a
friend of mine with a PhD in geology to
look at you to power and he sent me a
very long angry message about how quote
geologically and physically wrong it is
firstly the water wouldn't be able to
drain through holes that used to be
magma chambers because magma chambers
either erupt and have the rocks above
them collapse forming a caldera
or as is more likely have their contents
solidify and freeze into very hard rock
secondly even if all the water in the
oceans were to drain subsurface if user
power is anything like Earth then
temperatures will increase below the
surface by about 30 Celsius per
kilometer that you go down so a
subsurface ocean would exist either a
steam or a supercritical fluid and
because either would be less dense than
the surrounding rock it would rise to
the surface as geezers or other
geothermal activity which would make for
a really cool planet but not what we're
shown in the films
so in short there are a number of
problems with E to power thousands next
mygeeto is a freezing planet similar to
Hoth but the interior has completely
cooled and left the planet volcanic Li
dead the surface is covered with huge
crystals of all different kinds we've
already seen with hot and databar that
planets can be extremely cold and can be
geologically inactive so those features
on mygeeto of fine the massive crystals
are one of those cases where we might
have to allow artistic license
we know that huge crystals can form on
earth under the right conditions such as
the cave of crystals in Mexico so given
exactly the right set of conditions
migite could probably exist then lastly
we have Starkiller base a planet that
was hollowed out and turned into a
weapon that keeps the power of a star
inside itself in terms of the laws of
physics that's not how the force works
I think we just have to give them some
creative license with that one so of the
28 planets and moons we reckon that only
five couldn't exist in the real world
with some big uncertainties on some of
the others but none of the worlds in
star wars come even close to real
planets we've seen around other stars
out of the thousands of exoplanets have
been discovered
none surprise people like the planets we
now called hot Jupiters their gas giants
the size of Jupiter that orbit their
stars closer than mercury does to the
Sun and almost all orbiting in under
five days these giant planets are so
close to their stars that they're often
hotter than you would be sitting under a
rocket as it took off and that does
funky things to an atmosphere one such
hot Jupiter has high speed winds
whipping around over 5000 miles an hour
with cloud droplets made of molten glass
another has clouds they're likely formed
at the same substance that makes up
rubies and sapphires here on earth but
it's not just the giant planets that
have surprised us the planetary system
around the star trakis one has seven
earth sized planets orbiting it in such
a tight configuration that if life were
to exist there and reached our level of
Technology planet hopping would be an
easy holiday destination so while
science fiction might be strange it's
got a long way to go before it becomes
even stranger than science fact thank
you for watching this video
in making it dr. Wakefield and I have
made use of very real science to tackle
science fiction including tools from
astrophysics atmospheric physics and the
study of exoplanets now that I submitted
my thesis I have more time to make
science videos like this one which is
hopefully picture interest in the
science of planets and if atmospheres
but if you really want to understand
those concepts the only way to do that
is to tackle some problems yourself
during my PhD I found that I didn't
understand the topic fully until I'd
actually tried it myself and done some
problems if you'd like to support
science videos on this channel then go
to brilliant org forward slash Simon
Clarke and I'll put that down in the
description where you can sign up for
brilliant for free and in addition to
that first 200 people to use that link
will get 20% off their annual premium
subscription huge thanks to dr. waetford
for agreeing to
be in this video if you'd like to check
out her research or the card game about
female scientists through history which
we made together then check the links in
the description doing thanks also let's
go to my friends Tom Dowling and newly
dr. David Arnold for their help with the
script as well as checking out brilliant
dog forward slash Simon Clark if you'd
like to learn more about the science of
ice on earth and indeed other planets
then check out the link on the screen
and then the description to the crash
course which starts Dowling and I are
currently making on this channel lastly
though thank you again for watching if
you enjoyed the video please do give it
a like spread it on your social media
and if you'd like to see more videos
like this then hit the subscribe button
down there and comment below thank you
for watching I'll see you next time